Hello.
And welcome to today's episode.
Today, we are continuing the series with Laravel
working on a local development environment with Docker.
And we will also cover deploying our Laravel
application
with Kubernetes. Hopefully, the production like uncover all
the good bits in between.
As you'll seen in previous episodes, if you've
seen them, this is not always plain sailing,
but I will do my best to make
this work as best as we can.
I'm very fortunate today to be joined by
again, Kieran McNulty. Always a pleasure to have
you back. And a new guest today, we
have Alex Bowers who is our resident Laravel
expert who is gonna make sure that we
don't mess up too much again. Hey. How
are you both then? I'm good. Thank you.
No pressure, Alex. But now everything lies on
your shoulders as Kieran and I have proved
ourselves useless a few times now. So Well,
the odds and issue last week definitely wouldn't
have been something I caught because I did
not know that was a thing. So
yeah.
We'll see how it goes. Yeah. If I
don't sorry. I only got kitchen. I like
this new idea of drafting people in from
the comments.
Yeah.
You comment a lot. Come and join us.
I think what was
in fact, we got really lucky I think
last time and we'll cover what we we
went over. But the artisan file being used
to detect the root directory was actually a
random comment as well from someone that was
watching, which really saves us probably hours if
not days.
And then on that week or
We'll see how we get on today. I'm
not sure how many more of these we're
gonna have. I think we're close. We have
a pretty good setup. There's lot of stuff
in Laravel that's still not being covered yet
though.
Maybe
this is a bad idea. Alright.
Let's go for where we are. That's a
bit of a a recap. I'll pop up
my screen.
And
I think what we'll do is we'll start
with the
how do I expect this to work? Right?
So
what we have and I'll go over the
files in a moment.
But what we should have is an environment
where I can run
shell and everything should just be working. This
is the plan. Right?
That should spin up. In fact, we can
see it's got our MariaDB running. We have
a PHPFPM
container running, which is serving our PHP assets.
We have NGINX running, which is serving our
static assets,
and
we have
no no nodes. So we maybe didn't automate
that last time.
We did. The engine x doesn't depend on
it.
Alright.
So
should definitely
fix that.
Now if I take a look at our
PHP configuration,
I don't know. NGINX is serving. So browsing
to eighty eighty
should
get me something.
We've got some work to do. If if
we never use to log in, which is
something.
So PHP is working. It looks like it's
not it's a few stuff isn't working there.
Yes. So the chances are that in our
last episode, working with the the node
NPM style workflow, we just did our position
right now where we don't actually have those
assets being delivered. Is it worth just before
you do anything, be compiling all of those
assets just to make sure that they're all
present?
Hello, it says? Oh, no. Yeah. Got letter
4. 4 0 4. Okay. So
let's go over that then. So
our main focus last time was
this node workflow here.
Mhmm. What we wanted to do was provide
something that would run an MPM run watch
in the background continually
working on the asset completion for us. Now
this actually looks
okay, but the problem we had last time
was we needed Artisan to exist in order
for our assets to be put in the
right directory.
So let's confirm that.
And, David, that that volume, the assets were
being put into,
is it likely that's been removed from your
machine in the last week?
Yeah. Definitely.
For sure.
I I delete liberally.
So So we have to have never been
compiled yet. It might be all works if
we start there.
Okay. So first problem. There's no MPM container
running, and that's because our d shell environment
is very specific with the dependencies. And we
haven't actually made anything dependent or node dependency
because if I recall correctly, we had a
recursive dependency.
Don't remember that. Right?
We do. So let's take a look at
the make fail.
And We'll just spend a few minutes. I
think it's important to remember where we are
exactly rather than weighing in it. So
d shell environment spends up NGINX in the
background,
and then it spends up PHP
and our dependencies of PHP will be spun
up for us. So if we come back
to our Docker Compose file, we can see
that it depends on MariaDB and that is
created for us, but that is it. There's
nothing currently
that starts node.
Now if I remember correctly, the challenge with
automating that was
we have a shared volume between NGINX and
node. They're both consuming this public volume.
Mhmm.
And
could we get away with that? And we're
just saying that our PHP
no. Okay. So we can't add it to
PHP because PHP is a dependency on engine
x. And engine x wouldn't be able to
satisfy the dependency, but also depending on node.
So we can
let's see what happens. Yeah.
I see that. Right?
Alright.
So we're just gonna add that dependency. I
am gonna add the artist on file because
we did cover that. We know that the
assets go in the wrong direction
if we do not have
that fail existing.
Mhmm. Yeah.
And in theory, I should
be able to run this again.
We have a node container, so our watch
should be running.
And we got an exit one. Okay.
Let's put out the logs on our node
application.
Cross end of not found.
Interesting.
So
anyone know what cross env is?
It's a node package that's
the pain of my life whenever you try
and do stuff with NPM.
Okay. Perfect. So the problem here is NPM
run watch as in doing an NPM install
first. Yes.
Okay.
So the way that we wanna tackle that
is probably by bringing on a custom build
step where it runs a Docker image, which
is run NPM install as part of the
build process and then
no. Because we went to over we've got
the volume there.
So we need we actually need to do
this and say, we're gonna need to make
target that this runs that ensures the MPM
install happens before
the run watch install happens.
Yeah. We don't need to build it into
the image because this is a and sort
of a femoral
Exactly.
Then Plus we have the shared volume, which
would just blow away over the top of
it, so it wouldn't work. So okay. Step
one. Let's let's get this sorted then.
So we're gonna do
node assets,
which is going to ensure we have an
NPM install followed by an NPM
run
watch.
It's in central.
If we update our Docker compose file here,
where you can just say make.
And
I'm assuming that make is gonna exist inside
this container.
I was gonna ask that. How many people
try and make their containers pretty lean, don't
they? How many actually include Make?
Anything that's based on a Ubuntu Debian will
come with Make.
Pretty sure.
The Alpine variants generally don't
there we go. We're good.
You need to mount the Makefile as well
then.
Gotcha.
Hey, Aaron, on your keep already.
Oh, we might add our Makefile.
And by magic, we're running our one single
command that we want to be our entry
point to this application.
That looks pretty good.
Can you see the logs?
Logs.
Hold on.
Okay. MPM blah blah blah off the codes.
What we're assuming here then is when this
completes, I should be able to browse to
the application.
Should should.
So while that's working, let's encourage
people to ask oh,
well, we have some comments already. So yeah.
I was gonna say we should encourage people
to leave comments. We will act we'll answer
as many questions as we can handle.
And if you want us to cover that's
not been covered yet, feel free to let
us know in the comments too.
Okay. What do we got so far?
Oh, we got a comment from Robert. This
episode will be useful. Yep. I really hope
so.
I'm I'm really hoping this is the first
episode where we're not a problem driven development
and we actually, you know, can do the
things that we wanna do. But I'm not
gonna get I'm not gonna get make too
many assumptions.
Yeah.
Else have we got? So we have a
comment from
Mackey's.
You're brand new to this project. You're calling
the repo. How would I make sure my
note requirements were installed? Oh, we just answered
that by absolute sure luck. So yep. We
are using a meet target as part of
the node entry point there.
And We're just tackling that problem.
Good. So, yeah, keep those comments coming.
And
look at that.
Easy.
Easy. Alright.
So as pre populated the username and password,
which I'm gonna assume work.
Good. It's leading us on nicely to something
we haven't covered yet.
We got to run the migrations.
And we got to do the migrations.
How did you manage to log in last
time then? Had you run them manually in
DHL?
Yes. That we yeah.
Because that's I might have been episode one.
I should just check it all works.
Okay. So we're we're in pretty good shape
then. I'm happy with that. Mhmm. Because that
was a relatively easy fix. We got our
make fail. We added a target. We got
ours in.
Now we wanna handle common development tasks,
which is where our d shell environment comes
in. This here
is where we run all of the commands
that we would normally do if we were
building natively on the host. And in fact,
the setup that we have here works regardless
of a d shell. Right? If you can
use all of these make targets without ever
using the Docker setup. It's just there as
convenience
and
and for the parity thing, which I think
I rambled on a lot about the first
episode. So
I would suggest if we if okay. So
resident Laravel expert, that's his where you shine.
If I were if you were building a
Laravel application locally,
what would be your workflow for running the
migrations here? You
just run PHP arts and migrate.
Does that set up the table scheme as
well?
Yes. So the migrations
you have a database folder in the
I think the root folder
that will contain all of the migrations with,
a date prefix. It just runs on list
top down. In the database itself, there's a
migrations table that keeps track of
what migrations were run, rent, when, and handles
it all for you.
In in Laravel, creating a table is normally
a a mig it's always a migration. There
isn't a separate sort of create schema and
then
Not typically.
Although, you can make use of Doctrine's ORM,
which I believe is then driven based on
models or some I've never done that, but
you can make use of that with extra
packages.
Okay. So you're saying the workflow would just
be our design migrate?
Space migrate.
I'm assuming that creates the migration. Artisan
is about wrong as well.
Artisan
migrate.
Mhmm.
And now that's all your migrations done. You
should now be that's that's also in the
so you can run that again all the
time. And would there be CTA that I
need to load?
There can be. I assume this project probably
does. On the end of migrate, you can
do double dash seed.
I would do that locally, but never in
production. Or
you can do d b colon seed, which
is a separate command which does the same
thing.
So do we want that do you want
the migrations to run automatically when we enter
the d shell
or when we start the project?
I mean, it definitely could be we could
have some sort of make target called make
and it the handle then any bootstrapping commands.
And then, you know, again, we wanna replicate
native local development. I don't well, I I
have a lot of me every native command
I can with a make target.
This is just what people are used to
doing. I don't wanna remove that muscle memory,
that habit, all that stuff that they normally
do. Again, this is a I want them
to feel like this is just a local
machine only happens to be in a container.
Yeah. That's my goal here.
One one thing to note on that.
Quite often when I do development, I have
probably 10 tabs open. Oh, well, not necessarily
10, but a lot of tabs open of,
like, the same folder. What we'll have migrations
won't be tailing logs, all that sort of
stuff. If you just go into the d
shell, is that the same instance or are
they new instances each time you go into
it? You get a a new container every
single time.
But this it's gonna be pretty lightweight. I
would I I personally wouldn't be concerned about
that. But if we did think it was
gonna be a hassle, we could add a
t shell enter target which allowed you to
pop open more than one. You get, like,
a sudo t two I inside the same
container on a on a loop.
Yeah. The the overhead really of having loads
of containers running, especially on Linux, should be
the same as having loads of tabs open
Pretty close. Yeah. Yep. This is right. Because
there's no I think what's really important I
think Kieran's just kind of alluded to anyway,
but I'll I'll make it a little bit
more explicit. Is the opening a container without
a process running in it
doesn't have any overhead.
It's when I run the process, so that
process runs within the namespaces that we configure
in the host. So,
yeah, open it up. You're right. Running running
these containers is no different from really opening
up a new shell process on your your
local machine. Yeah. Because they enter your cache.
Although, might be an overhead on non Linux
platforms.
Normally, would say I don't support those, but
I know I found myself confined to a
Mac. So I'm having to support this use
case, but we'll see. We'll see how it
goes. But but let me show that working
then. Right? So if I just jump down
here and split this. Oh, how do I
do the other split?
I see. Okay. Because it is mixed up.
Make the shell.
Just ensure no dependencies are running.
Have I oh, there's no p s command
here. I'm gonna show you that there's nothing
else running.
Sure.
It's gonna be the same regardless, but
this is you just need to trust me.
This is this container. In fact, the IDs
are different. There we go.
EFB.
So these are different containers,
But I can still open as many as
I might want. It's pretty lightweight.
The seats the seats worked.
I have a login.
I've now got some sort of a way
to view the $500 page, the photo for
error page.
I've got my menus. This application well, besides
is that You left with the CSS, didn't
you, to test and watch?
What do you mean by If you're to
change back the default
tailwind config, you'd be able to see stuff,
I guess. Alright. Let's see. Get this.
At least I get status.
I don't see that. Oh, because I've pushed
it since so the code was available for
everyone.
Alright. Let's see. Where is the CSS again?
It is This is tailwind config file. Oh,
tailwind config. Nice.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Those templates.
I can get the defaults if you want
and I can just replace them. So if
you need to rewrite those.
I was hoping it would give him a
hover with the diff, which normally quite nicely
does for me, but not today.
Yeah. I'll let you drop in some value.
I otherwise, I would have made them all
white or black or red or whatever just
to fix the menu.
So we just have one other problem last
time as well. Right? And the challenge was
I modified the view fail. This is why
I changed the tailwind fail. Right? Because we
modified the view thing, reloaded the page,
and I never actually seen the update.
But to confirm that it was the live
reloading was working, I modified the tail when
the configuration.
So I guess we should
once we revert these values back to the
proper colors, which Alex is doing right now,
perfect.
We should make another change to the view
and see if our new node runner has
fixed that configuration.
There. That's better. Yeah. So you were trying
to check that
text dashboard
dashboard file right now.
Yeah. So where was that? Was that
let's
go to
app.
Nope.
Was in resources.
Resources,
JavaScript,
pages,
dashboard.
Dashboard. Index. Yeah.
Alright. Okay. So my five is here.
I changed that in more yeah. Then the
bottom too.
And do we have the five? Yeah. We
do have the five there. So in theory,
I've
I should
It just works.
Yep.
Well, how this is gonna be the first
episode where everything just goes plain sailing.
Now that I've said that, it probably just
jinxed everything. But
With the question
about the migrations, Alex. Do people sort of
roll up the migrations on a big project?
So something came out new in Laravel eight,
which was released about a month ago Mhmm.
Which is where you can
combine previous
migrations into a schema file, and it will
handle all that stuff for you now. That
but that is a a recent feature. It's
not something that's been around for long.
Because I know those I know that MariaDB
container has a
feature where you can pass it a special
file location that will run dot SQL files
in that location.
Okay. Well, I
think you still need to make use of
the arson migrate command. It sort of like
it figures this out how to run that
alongside your current migrations and stuff.
I'm not sure whether it does anything clever
other than just, like, run that file first
and migrate afterwards. I don't know. What what
you can do I I don't I haven't
done it with Laravel, but you can sort
of dump your entire database into a dot
SQL file.
Run that, and that would include the migrations
table. So then Ah. And when you run
the does prefer. It's all the ones that
it's it's kind of done already that that
snapshot has.
I'm not sure because I don't think it
takes all of your data unless your migrations
themselves put data in. I'm not sure on
that, but I think it's
to some extent intelligent.
I'm not sure.
Right. Okay. We have a a question then.
So Robert is saying, does hot module reload
work or is this not part of the
Laravel basic package? So
I'm not really sure what the hot module
reload
we're talking about here. Is that something you're
familiar with, Alex? Yeah. So when you're making
changes
in JavaScript or CSS or whatever, if you're
changing, for example, a value and it requires
you to reload a page, that's not necessarily
ideal depending on the type of application you're
dealing with and where what is you're doing.
If it takes, like, 12, like, 12 pages
to get to the same point of, like,
filling in out a form or something, it's,
like, a single page application. You don't have
to do that.
So hot module reloading reloads just that one
section of CSS or that one section of
JavaScript or whatever.
Reloads the page, like, behind the scenes, fetching
in the new values so it's updated
without you having to, like, refresh the page.
Okay. So that change I made there should
have automatically just showing up. Yeah. That would
have just when you by time you got
back, it would have just, like, been there
as if you'd done a reload, but you
hadn't.
Okay. So that automatic I'm assuming that the
way that we work with NPM
run watch
is handling that?
I believe that Laravel Mix
has a different mode. Not because it has
it requires like a separate server running in
the background Yeah. To handle the reloads.
So this could this could get interesting, actually.
Similar, doesn't it? You have some extra JavaScript
gets injected into the page for the Yeah.
To get then
polls the back end server for updates. Yeah.
So if you do you do
MPM run hot. Yeah. MPM run hot.
Alright. Okay. So I there are some things
required here. We'll see if we need to
tweak the host in the port to work
in the Docker setup, but let's get the
run hot. Now does the run hot work
alongside run watch or does it replace
run watch? Instead of okay.
Might be Right. Let's
see if we get this working then. So
that means I wanna change or make target.
It should be the simple
alright.
So
we'll drop out this. We don't need to
log anymore. We know that works.
Pop open our detail again.
And then I look cute oh,
I've got key. See, I'm I'm still getting
this whole command and alt being in the
wrong way problem. But, I mean, that's okay.
So
this is our hot version of JavaScript running.
I'm assuming if I change a fail, I'll
see something here.
I'm also gonna pop this open. I'll get
my two back. So let's refresh that.
And let's try
And that probably loaded extra JavaScript in the
page. So it's good to have refreshed there.
I'll do a hard refresh just in case.
Right.
So now let's change that dashboard file again.
21.
Why not?
I'm not sure which one of these are
meant to be changing.
I didn't see anything particularly
Oh, the metal is the title tags, the
ones that the the guy says in the
comments. Alright.
I I I didn't see anything happen here,
but let's just
and that's what that's still visible.
But it's okay. So that the JavaScript bit
is definitely
getting a change, but we're getting a problem
here.
So it looks like we are gonna be
diving into this configuration.
A quick look in dev tools to see
what connections it's making.
That's a good idea.
See if it's getting a four zero four
to somewhere.
Let's try. Yep. Let's go for the network
one.
See if we got a WebSocket or something.
WebSocket.
Yeah. I don't see anything
obvious here.
Do we have any console letters? No.
This is the kind of problem where you
have to understand how it actually works
to to figure out what to fix.
So the hot the hot compiles a version
of the assets that we have served through
NGINX. Right? We're confident that's working.
It's the hot version.
Believe so. Otherwise, the compiled version the compiled
files, like well, you could test that by
removing the public folder, like CSS or something
like that and
run hard and just see if that continues
to work, I guess.
It should just
So that explains
why it should just work, though.
Yeah. But there's things like
on.
P r t answer. Have we meant to
be doing that? No. That's just instead of
doing
just like,
funding PHP and FPM and stuff. I'll send
serve just the same thing. But does it
do some,
like, stuff like Okay. So I think that
the challenge here is MPM run halt
opens a server.
So this actually runs something on port eighty
eighty for those connections.
Which we aren't exposing. Which we're not exposing.
So let's expose that
and see if that triggers something.
Although that port's the same as what we
are actually binding to us. So let's let's
change that first.
Do want any error messages like combine support?
Let's go with 8,000 here. We'll expose note
on
and also, I'm gonna assume that the assets
aren't compiled or transferred or whatever is happening
with the hot reload and it's maybe actually
serving them over that port that may trigger
injection of some code.
So we need to make sure we handle
that just in case.
Mhmm. Let's spin this all back up then.
But I'm just going
put it away. Spin it back up
by any chance.
Okay.
Now I'm gonna have to run these
MPM install is gonna take longer now. I
shouldn't have done the volumes.
If you if
you control c on
Docker Compose, is that the same as Docker
Compose one?
No. The actual c inside of a t
shell only shuts down that container.
No. Sorry. In the
when you run it, not in the background
without the dash d option.
If you can see, is that a stop
or a down?
A stop.
It
doesn't destroy everything as much.
Alright. So we just need to give
yeah. See, there's this WDS,
which I'm assuming is the
the
thing. So we're it it may be that
we actually need to remove NGINX if we
want the live reload to work.
Well, you can you can change the port
in the mix config if that's the issue.
No. So it's not the port. The problem
is is that our
as as we have it set up right
now, our NPM run hot is generating assets,
which will then be delivered over NGINX and
not via
this.
Although it could be that this is an
additional port.
So maybe that's webpack as an actual web
server server and assets, but it's just that
web socket connection. I'm not really sure. I
don't I think we're gonna have to kinda
poke it a little bit and see what
happens. Like, if I just browse to this,
what will I get? Do I get the
assets directory? Do I get
You won't be able to browse to that
because that's internal to the
container, isn't it? So local host is referring
to a different IP address. Oh, no. I
just exposed it with a port forward. This
connection was reset tells me I wanted an
upgrade to a WebSocket and it failed. So
I'm gonna assume it's not serving the assets
and all it's doing is serving WebSocket for
the reload. So this the existence of that
port as a WebSocket connection may mean that
something happens
here.
Maybe.
And so if we go to 8,000
It's crazy.
Trying to filter by web socket.
Migrations again? Yep. Let's get the migrations up
and running. So PHP
artisan migrate.
Let's see.
If this happens a third time, we're gonna
add the migrations to the d shell command.
Pop this back up.
And p m install?
That's still running. Yeah. You're you're right.
No. No. It's finished. Can
you look at the
console then? Because that might indicate that it's
not found any of the assets.
Yeah.
Alright.
So what's going on here?
Maybe a change between
NPM run hot and NPM run watch.
If we switch it back to a watch,
does it work?
Maybe
they're not something that you could directly swap
out. It's kind of my
my thought process. I wish thought you could.
That's why I make a file.
What was that? Sorry.
Missed something. Why was that looking at port
8,000?
Well, I moved
engine x support 8,000 so that I could
expose the WebSocket from node.
Okay.
Yeah.
Okay. So let's Oh, wait. Are the assets
they're looking for $80.80 or 80 80,000? Sorry.
They were looking for 8,000,
which is where they are. They should but
they should not be looking for eighty eighty,
should they know for the library loading stuff
to work? Or if that's just a WebSocket
connection? My assumption right now. It it depends.
So if yeah. If they get if they
get them initially from NGINX and then get
updates from
webpack, then
they should load them initially from NGINX. But
it should work anyway. Right?
My understanding on the documentation is that it's
that they should always now refer to eighty
eighty. Okay.
Excuse me.
Alright. Everything
oh, because I haven't restarted the note container
with a new command.
Once it let's just check the watch works
and and that all goes back to normal.
And then we've
we'll change it back to hot and we'll
start modifying the mix config to do
what I think we maybe need to make
it do.
What one third one thing worth looking at
is what changed to the mix manifest file
happens when you wouldn't get in the hot?
Because that tells it where all the assets
are held, like, where the assets are living.
And maybe those files aren't exposed.
Okay. Let's tackle this one
thing of it. Oh, time. So there was
a lot more output here
from the run watch than there was from
the run hot. The run hot did not
do any of
this.
Yeah. It's doing stuff like
versioning.
Alright. So we're we're back.
As far as web sockets go, we didn't
get any trying to open.
So let's copy this. I'll comment it out.
We're not gonna put it in directly.
So actually, this might completely
simplify the way we're doing the assets because
in dev, we maybe don't need to have
a shared volume at all.
If everything comes in on
server.
How do you mean? Sorry.
If the if the operating mode is that
in
in dev, we use hot module reload and
all of the assets are served from that
webpack server.
It means we don't have to serve anything
through any of the static assets through NGINX
and a lot of the stuff we did
last time we can chuck.
I
wouldn't necessarily say that hot module reloading is
the way that everybody does it. A lot
of people don't bother. It depends on the
type of application that you're dealing with because
some people who are doing single page applications
will find it more useful than people who
are doing a standard
service side rendered application.
Yeah. I guess if your page is reloading
every time you click something.
Yeah. It's not it. Yeah. It's it's not
an issue. Whereas if you're doing service side
a single site single
page applications, then it becomes more of an
issue because
where you are on the page matters more
in front end rendering as well. Mhmm.
Okay.
So
also what I've read here is that if
your application isn't using this syntax for the
assets, then it's not gonna be able to
do hot reloading.
And we haven't really confirmed that ping does
that. I'm just checking it now.
Alright. It does make use of that stuff
so it should be fine. Alright. So we're
gonna bring back and run hot. We're gonna
open up our mix file.
Webpack dot mix.
Yep.
And
this lane here,
which they're falling off my buffer.
See what that's with local host. Right?
Yeah.
So this turns on hot model reload. It's
kinda what I'm getting from it. HMR options,
blah blah blah.
So let's
what did I change? Restart
node.
So that should now switch to running an
MPM run hot again.
And then we jump back into a d
shell
and see what happens.
K.
Run like it said failure then. Yeah. That
was just because I killed and restarted the
container. Okay. Okay. So we now got serving
on eighty eighty, which we're exposing locally.
Let's just see what happens.
I mean, things working.
So I guess it's click into, like, organizations.
Okay. That seems okay. So if you make
a change to the
something now, I guess it should change.
Yeah. But I can't see a WebSocket open.
I changed the dashboard.
But that But well, none of this is
server side rendered. So that if you change
that to 23, that must be fine.
But I guess change it to 24 now
25.
No. It's not doing that, is it? Actually
That's you refreshing right there. Yeah. So that's
the hot not even yeah. That's so that's
just what I was worried about. That's the
MPM run hot isn't actually doing any compilation
of assets.
Isn't it?
Well, no. I just changed that template
refreshing the page manually, and I'm still not
seeing that update.
Although, we do see a compilation step here.
Okay. So what's I think it's doing that.
It's compiling it, and then it's pushing the
new compiled
asset
across the WebSocket
rather than and not probably not saving it
to disk.
Yeah. I think you're you're right, which means
NGINX is never gonna be able to serve
this.
So we probably if we want hot module
reloading,
we'd need to pull out NGINX and serve
the JavaScript over.
But it should be doing that automatically already.
The
the file
what do you call them? Like, the file
URL should be referencing port eighty eighty now
and not the other one. Do we need
to
control the assets once
the volume using
make assets
so that the compiled JavaScript knows it's using
mix? Because I think since we edited the
mix config, we haven't actually compiled the assets.
I'm happy to try it.
Just yeah. Try just running it once
and then
I'm I'm just
because I'm gonna request one of these assets
over that socket. And I just curiosity is
getting the better of me right now. So
and then
Yeah. Because what I think might have happened
is Yeah. See, this is coming over 8,000.
This isn't eighty eighty. I'm pretty sure that
should be eighty eighty. Yeah. But there's no
way for the browser to know that. Right?
Because the version we're serving on Port 8000
is the one we compiled
fifteen minutes ago before we changed anything.
So nothing to tell the web browser. You
should be looking at WebSocket.
That doesn't work.
I think we need to compile it with
yeah. Run the NPM whatever command we had,
the the non hot one.
Run that once and see if it changes.
Alright. So I will cheat and jump inside
of notes
and do NPM run dev.
I wonder if artisan serve has something baked
in to make this work.
I don't think so because I've done it
I'd never used artisan seven. I've had hot
hot module reloading work before.
So then so now I do a false
reload in your browser and see what see
what's what.
Everything's still served over 8,000.
If you do
run run hot again and then have a
look at the mix manifest file.
K. We'll restart.
Frogs.
So you want me that's just the old
one failing, so we'll give that a second.
Which manifest file do you want me to
look at? I think it's in public slash
mixed dot manifest. I think it's called a
mixed manifest dot JSON, something like that.
Indeed.
Right. After you do hot, does that change?
Or if you just run hot there? Yeah.
We're still giving output, is it?
Go away doc. There we go. That's what
we're looking at. Isn't the one that's in
the volume?
Yeah. The one in the volume is the
one that might matter. Well, won't matter.
Alright. So what we're seeing is we have
a public directory here with a mixed manifest.
Never mind. I was expecting that to say
maybe have the port numbers in it or
something.
And it has been modified right now,
and there's a hot directory.
Okay.
Hot file.
Right. And that's got the so that needs
to be exposed to the PHP one because
Laravel mix has a PHP
mix function that's exposed to the Laravel, and
that will be checking if there's a hotfail
to get the
server from that rather than
for it to be
Right. It makes sense in my head. Don't
know how to explain it, but I think
that file needs to be exposed.
I should be able to have a port
8,000
hot. Right? That's why we we need that,
which it works, actually.
But is that exposed to
Yeah. We had this we had this on
the engine export.
But is that exposed to PHP was the
question.
So it would need to be able to
see that volume would be mapped into the
PHP container.
Why would the PHP container need that when
it's FPM that's running? It doesn't actually know
about hot reloading or this file.
And we're not using artisan serve. If we
were using artisan serve, I would understand. But
I'm assuming this hot I mean, we don't
even have a request to hot on the
PHP side here
on the network tab.
No.
Because it's looked it'll be like a floating
the file with PHP.
You don't see PHP request. They happen inside
of the app.
So
Yeah.
What if you like? Yeah. If you go
into the PHP
Docker container and paste that file there now
or well, then the file or something there,
does it start working?
So it's server side using hot and then
changes what it's sending to the
browser. K. So we don't have the hot
file there. And what we're saying is if
I echo
HTTP
one two seven zero zero one
hot
to this. I forget the port.
It wasn't hot on there. It was colon
eighty eighty. That's all I had, I think.
Okay.
So
it's just the base of URL. And I
think maybe a trailing slash.
Yeah. Yeah. But we can we can check.
Right? So Yeah. It's probably worth checking.
Okay. So This is exactly what we have
there.
It's a bit like the artisan file thing.
You've had you know, they're they're quite tightly
integrated with PHP and the JavaScript. And and
the way we're trying to way we've been
trying to approach it is this quite separate
pipelines.
Maybe they might.
Yeah.
So that has broken out, which is good.
I think it's now
yeah. We can see asset request from port
eighty eighty.
But that's
So that that's actually doing what we wanted
to do. It's just a shame the request
is failing. You
have got an extra slash in here which
probably isn't helping although
So it doesn't have a trading slash where
we added it. It shouldn't have a trading
slash. As though that's not serving the asset
anyway.
So what's going on with run hot?
Let's go back into the node container. I
think we're close. So
Can we can
we fix the hot file in the PHP
container?
Yes.
I will do that.
Just a moment. I wanna be able to
curl
eighty eighty j s zero dot j s.
And I can from a node container.
From here
Is 8080 definitely exposed properly?
I'm not gonna say definitely, but I'm pretty
confident.
Yeah. But it's not working there. It needs
to be exposed from the node container. Right?
Hold on. I bet you there's a problem.
So MPM run hot as an actually binding
on all the interfaces. We need to fix
that. Okay. Got it. I can fix this.
So that's good. Listening on local host not
on zero zero zero zero. Yeah. So this
is the port that we wanna bind, not
actually where we wanna be delivered.
We're gonna bind on all interfaces on port
eighty eighty. If we do this
and let's restart node there,
And our logs down here, we should see
this is running on 000
80 80, which means I can have that
from my browser.
That should work.
It should work.
Let's get the logs running again.
I'll just tackle a question right there. So
Robert's asked what's good practice for preserving the
DB in the dev environment.
So
we're already configured MariaDB to use a volume.
So you can count the containers and the
database as preserved.
The only reason it died for me and
I have to migrate again is because through
don't know if it's good or bad habit,
but this dash v on the Docker Compose
down will remove all the volumes as well.
So I actually explicitly told it not to
preserve the database state, which was the which
was the problem.
And then for prod, your database will be
handled completely differently.
We can talk about that a little bit
later.
Okay. This is better.
Which means if I hit refresh, we've got
assets on that port. Now
we can refresh this page.
What's not gonna work right now? Oh, no.
It's working. Oh, yeah. That PHP fails still
exist. So we have to automate that. We
can't forget.
But we should have reloading there.
Do we agree?
Yeah. But it won't work because you're loading
on pause you're loading IP 0000
from the front end, is wrong.
If you look in your requests
So there must must be something in this
configuration option then where I can say bind
on this IP, but really we are delivering
it over something else.
So
let's go to
is it Laravel Laravel?
What are looking for the mix stuff?
Yeah. I'm looking for the code.
No. It's Jeffrey Way slash Laravel dash mix.
Jeffrey Way.
Laravel
mix.
The search. Okay.
Okay.
I'll just search Laravel Laravel. Let's see if
I can find that option.
So it's
It's not part it's so it's only part
of Laravel mix.
Okay. That's our goal. Maybe just lying to
me.
I sent you an yeah.
Cool.
So we wanna understand
this configuration.
It only looks like you get the two
config options.
Yeah. Then that's not gonna work.
Yeah. Okay.
It's it's just
I was gonna say it's it's purely designed.
It's not intended for container sales. That's never
gonna work. I I can't listen on all
interfaces and
rewrite.
No.
Yes. What's
it you You can't you
could you not make it use a specific
IP and have the IP be, like,
a Docker network? Or is that not I
I wouldn't go down that route. It's too
cumbersome, too painful.
Instead, what I want is to just put
see, the the disconnect here is when we
run a server, we have the binding address
and then listen.
The binding address and where we wanna route
traffic is different in a container setup.
So all
I really wanna be able to do is
tell this webpack configuration to bind on all
ports, but still rewrite things to one two
seven.
There's a relevant question in the chat.
The service name,
it's a good idea, but it won't work
locally.
So, you know, browsing to
the node
DNS name on my local machine wouldn't work.
I've had I mean, we could force that
to work
and that I could
set something on my host files that satisfied
that. But again, I don't want that. I
want everything to be contained in in this
configuration.
Could you make it
inside of the actual
container
itself where local host wasn't one two seven,
but instead zero zero zero zero?
Because that's only based on the host file,
I believe, is it?
I mean, it's not exactly clean, but it
would do it, maybe.
Yes. A Rawkode engine host file.
Sounds like a dreadful idea. Is
there some host names in Docker Compose?
We can do some stuff with host names,
but, again, it's a territory usually
doing bad things.
Okay.
Do we know what is actually running this
web pack server that's serving the assets?
Is it yeah. Okay. So it's just webpack
dev server. Right? This is what we got
here. Yeah.
So let's go take a look at webpack
dev server.
Yeah. I'm thinking the
extra host setting in Docker Compose
to do what Alex was suggesting.
Okay. So dev server has an allowed hosts,
which tells me that it's not it's not
always gonna run on a one two seven
binding.
That's something
strange.
Yeah. It's
tricky.
I mean, this the 000
is working because I can have it from
my local machine. The problem is just to
rewrite inside now.
Well, an alternate option then is that you
after the compile stuff happens, instead of
letting
Laravel mix actually change your
hot file, you instead just force write it
yourself.
There's a good point, actually.
Because we don't actually care about We haven't
modified
the hot file. It still says one two
seven.
No. No. That would have been modified by
It can. No. The volume isn't shared between
those containers. HP containers only got the file
because they've
SSH didn't write it.
So the existence of this file is what
happens. It's not actually using the value to
rewrite the pass.
Is that something we can leverage?
I think it is using the value for
the initial page load, and then the rest
of it is done with the hot server.
So if you do a hard relash reload
on this page, is it using eighty eighty
to begin with? Oh, look. Yeah. And then
it's the and then it's the server itself,
the node web server, which is then returning
the new assets,
like endpoints.
That's annoying.
Which means that if you were to go
into the hot hot module server
and look at the hot file in that
one, that will have zero zero zero.
And then if you were to change that
to be eighty eighty or whatever at the
moment. Now if you change that one and
then reload the browser, it should
work.
But then as soon as you do a
hot recompile, it will break again.
So that's loaded everything. But now if if
you change an asset, that file will break.
Oh, it it it failed.
Oh.
Oh, no. That's that zero dot zero dot
zero dot zero is actually working.
That's a red heading. Yeah. Okay. So we
don't care.
How is that working?
I'm I'm not gonna argue. I'm assuming 0000
is just resolving in the browser to to
local host. 000080800.
I had no idea. That was a thing.
So we're trying to fix something that's not
a problem. Okay. Cool. So What what what
goes on to this? Because I've seen those
little red lines through it and got worried.
Okay. Right. Right. And I assumed it was
failing, but there's a 200 here. So
and we have a WebSocket connection. So okay.
We got completely sidetracked there for something that
wasn't a problem.
So let's
So the bit we
yeah. Check it works.
Amazing. So that made yeah. So that works
without a PHP refresh. Okay.
But we had to manually write that file
in the PHP container to make it work.
K. So let so let's fix that then.
Right? So what we need for the hot
reload scenario is
it failed to exist.
So if we take a look at how
our PHP is configured,
we mount
all of this.
So
I mean, it's probably as simple as just
saying
echo.
Only if you're running hot, though. If you're
not running hot, you don't want that file
there. Because that file will make everything break
because it will be expecting it to run
through hot one when it isn't.
But I guess we're deciding But but we
are deciding. We but right now, we've got
our node assets. It's always gonna run hot.
So
I'm comfortable.
And this being the node Come on. Well,
how else would we do it?
Yeah. Shouldn't this be in the node assets
target?
Which runs automatically anyway. I mean, I yeah.
I mean, I can do that. So at
least the code is script together, it makes
a bit more logical sense. But implementation
wise, it's the exact same.
Mhmm. Alright. So I'm not gonna destroy
my volumes, but I am gonna shut everything
down.
And that backup, then we should get live
roll live hot reloading by default
and everything work. If you don't destroy the
volumes, how will you know necessarily that the
hot file got written to the right place?
Because it's They're not in a volume. Yeah.
There's no volume. Okay. So
I'm just gonna run make b shell.
Our Rawkode is gonna handle everything for me.
We will need to just keep an eye
on our logs on the node site.
We can see the echo run. That's great.
Can see it's a cross end node. No.
We don't want it on the node server.
We want it on the PHPFPM one, don't
we? It is. It's just Kieran wanted to
bundle it with that automation, but it does
happen on the PHP side.
So this happens with
oh, no. That does run-in the
That one's on the note. Hold on.
Don't your key on. You're wrong.
Oh my god. D shell here is the
that's the PHP container. Yeah. That's our interactive
development environment and say oh, no. Yeah. And
saved. And actually, it's right in that file
locally on the disk, so it's gonna be
available here
for the container. But I'm I'm I'm okay
with this step. It's
assuming that fails and they get ignore. Yep.
It is. It's not it's not, you know,
wait,
which means we can
now monitor
node again.
Once that's happy, we should be able to
oh, where's my
Third time.
Why did that?
Awkward.
We kept in containers, We're
not using the volume. We're not using the
volume.
Okay. Let's just let's process the database. So
I'm sorry. I lied to everybody.
We will
make sure that we do persist this volume.
We're using the named volume and
bar lab
my s q l.
I
think that's right. The way that we would
confirm that
is to do a docker image
spec MariaDB.
What version? 10.
And
you
should see the volumes listed
by the MySQL.
So now we've got persistence there, which means
I do need to run migrations one more
time, but that will be it.
I promise.
Okay. So
we should get home module reloading
by default. There's our WebSocket. That's a really
good start. I'm gonna modify our template one
more time.
Resources,
JavaScript, pages, dashboard,
view.
I am live.
Reload.
Awesome.
That's pretty nice.
Alright.
We got a couple of comments. Let's see
what we have here.
Tony says first time viewer, where should I
start?
If you're interested in Laravel and PHP, start
with
part one of this. This is part three.
If you're really, really curious, there was a
non Laravel specific one where we covered a
lot of the groundwork with Docker. And if
you go to
let me do this live. Let's see how
fancy I can get.
With
the rockcode.live/PHP,
you will see all of my PHP videos.
Thank you for watching. Now
Is it worth having a Laravel
save playlist on on
YouTube. I am gonna add a Laravel tag.
In fact, does Laravel work? Was I was
I smart enough to go ahead and do
that?
It was. There you go. Rawkode.live/Laravel.
You'll see we're live right now with this
one.
There's the part ones and two Laravel edition
and Kieran and I also
is that only three weeks ago? Wow.
There's a deeper dive into the the general
PHP server Docker Compose here before I had
my my brand in setup. Anyway, thank you
for your question. Let's see. We've got
well, it's in. Hello. Nice to see this
live. Yeah. Very much live and very much
when things go wrong, know about it just
as well as we do. And I like
covered up Keaton's face. Sorry, mate.
And we got Robert's in
oh, yeah. He's answered my question for me.
Thank you very much, Robert's.
Okay.
I can't believe things are working. We almost
we almost went down a rabbit hole that
we didn't have to go down, but we
fixed it. So.
We know you got caught up by another
rogue file that exists somewhere.
It's supposed to work. So
Nice. Yeah. And who knows? We've learned to
do that. Browser to zero dot zero dot
zero dot zero results to local host, which
is really convenient. Otherwise, this reloading would probably
have been a lot problematic, and we'd have
to specify
the extra configuration. We'd have to contribute something
to mix to say, I wanna bang on
this, but lessing on this. Might be worth
doing that anyway because I don't know how
reliable it would be to rely on zero
zero zero zero actually going to one two
seven. That's
that's nice.
It might be worth improving
open source just in general. Whoever gets the
opportunity to do that might be worth doing
that just in general. Yeah. It probably depends
on what audio network adapters are in or
something.
Okay. So
how is this is this is this a
fully working Laravel local development environment?
No. No.
So
there's two there's two sections which I can
think of immediately off the top of my
head, would be useful.
That is the
there's something called the scheduler, which is just
cron,
and there's
the queue system as well.
Yeah. And then alongside that, there's a load
of separate things which are useful, like
search and things like that, which
are sort of
work based on things like classic search running
or
and there's also caching, which runs based on
Redis or m m caching as well. And
does Peng CRM have any of those components?
Probably not because it's only a demonstration of
the ping JS, like, library, which is
it's not a fully flesh level application. That
it is just a a demonstration of how
to use, like, ping how to use inertia.
Okay. So I think
the best
protocol here would be that we find a
more feature complete Laravel application for another episode
where we tackle scheduling cron and stuff and
focus on what we can do with this
example so that we can kinda call it
as complete as we're gonna get. Mhmm. The
only thing I think we're missing
right now is how do I run the
tests and how do I deploy it to
Kubernetes?
Let's do tests.
Test
test should be easy. Right? Yes. Makes tests.
Doesn't it? We we don't have to deploy
it without running the test. So Test test.
So test test is working.
Yeah. Oh, that that does remind me that
there is a
I I don't know again whether or not
PingCRM
covers this, but there's a browser based testing
in Laravel, a package called Laravel Dusk, which
makes use of Chrome WebDriver
to, you know, go through click buttons, all
that sort of stuff. Doing that in Docker
could be a fun topic.
Yeah.
Definitely.
Because when things go wrong, it gives you
screenshot outputs. It it does all that sort
of stuff. So you'll need to have, like,
yeah, probably some
heavy debugging in that one. So I have
run Puppeteer and containers before. That will be
fun. But not part of the Ping CRM
project. So I think the vibe I'm getting
right here is we need another application to
continue the CDs on.
But let's still continue with what we have
for Ping CRM. We still got, what's this,
another twenty minutes. Are you gonna contribute this
back at the end, though?
Sorry? Are you gonna contribute this to Ping
at the end?
If they want it, they can have it
for sure.
Okay.
Woah. What's going on here?
We had this last time. This is because
one of us,
maybe me,
has the file open.
It was a sharing issue last time. So
Yeah. I think it's just a weird quirk.
Okay.
Now
let's talk about this. We we we don't
have a Docker file right now for building
this and distributing it. Oh, we do. Okay.
So let's take a look at our Docker
file. How far do we get with this?
Could be
four. Alright. We have a base layer where
we add our dependencies. We've got the dev
layer, which is the one we target for
actually working.
And
then we build an FPM container to ship
to prod, which we kinda started on. Oh,
we have tests. So we have, you know,
that but that's really important as well that
we put this inside the Docker file. It
means when we do the Docker image build,
we're running the test that can run happily
inside the build process. And actually, we don't
build an image of those test fail. If
that step fails, there's no artifact. There's no
Make test target.
And we have a make test target.
Ta da.
Because it was only at one point. So
that's good.
Yeah. So
after test fail, I mean, we could always
artificially make a test fail if we want.
But when I do a Docker image build,
we we're never gonna get a container image
out of that because this fails, which is
which is good. What we the guarantee of
the
the process we're trying to encourage
or enforce here is that if a Docker
image build passes, that is an image I
can ship.
Assuming or I can also run other types
of tests against that which are also equally
important like the puppeteer test. When I run
integration or end to end test, the chances
are I want to use the artifact that
I'm gonna ship to prod and run the
test against the and then tear it back
down.
No. We're not gonna be able to do
that. I think we definitely need to try
and find a more feature could be application
that has all of these additional components.
But we can ship this to we can
ship this to our fake prod of Kubernetes.
So the test that passed by the time
you build the image will be sort of
internal tests,
the self tests?
Yeah. And if anything that doesn't have dependencies,
I would run-in the part of the Docker
image build process. Like, I don't want my
CI system to be complicated. My CI system
should be Docker image build and that's it.
All I want it to be. And I
target
build f p m, which is our
production
PHP image that we're building here.
But we never got the also order working,
I don't think. Why did we comment that?
That's just production optimization.
You don't want that in development. But that's
just the production image we're building with that
one. Yeah. So it's spelled FPM. I mean,
it's purely named, but it's spelled FPM for
production.
That's what we're supposed to take away from
that.
Yeah. I don't because
the I think we were hitting some more
than we
fix
it. The problem was we then we we
actually decided we didn't want composer available in
the production image. So we actually wanted to
extract the composer installed to dump out a
loader to its own step and then have
a production image that pulls down all of
the vendor directory and stuff when we just
never got around to it. This is annoying
thing with Composer is that you have to
have all of the files there to optimize
the auto loader because it scans all the
files.
So whereas you can do the vendor directory
generation
just with the composer JSON.
So so then so you could move the
composer install out,
but the dump auto loader has to happen
after you've copied everything.
Yep.
Okay. So we also have a question here.
Sorry. Sorry, Kieran. The way we've got it
there, we're copying the composer JSON, and then
immediately, we're copying the
everything
on sixteen and eighteen, which is a bit
messy. Yeah. I think we were just kinda
faffing around with it at that point. We
haven't really decided what our what our kinda
goal was. So
Leo has popped in
one day sorry, Kieran. I'll just keep covering
you up. One day say to put in
the test and so Docker fails, you can't
paralyze steps in CI.
That's
half true. There's some changes that do allow
you to do that. So I'll talk about
that in a second.
You followed that up with unit test. That's
not a problem.
Integration test can be slow. Okay. So
if you're using build kit,
you do get parallelism on the Docker image
build. So you can do Docker build kit
equals one Docker image
build dash t. Let's call it PHP prods
and I need a target of build
m dot.
And I run this. You'll see the output
is different
than what you would normally expect. And that's
as parallel. So what that means is it
creates a a bag, a graph of all
these steps. And if there are steps that
do not have any dependents on each other,
they all run on their own core
and parallel
as quite fast.
Once you build the image, this is why
the unit tests are okay here because we're
just running them to confirm that the image
that we're building, it's almost gonna work. You
know, we've done some testing on it. And
then you could parallelize integration tests however you
want.
Whether that be through multiple containers or
given a container access to multiple cores and
then that we have the internal workings of
it. Like, whatever that is, it's fine. It
depends what kind of integration tests we're talking
about as well. Because if you're talking about
integration tests that are testing a module inside
your PHP application,
you can still run them pretty quickly as
part of this build.
The ones that are normally slow are the
ones that are depending on IO,
and they're the ones that will need other
containers involved to to to run the test.
So they're the ones you'd be testing afterwards
after the build. You know, running any tests
that need a database because you have to
have your image and your and your database.
Exactly.
Alright. Let's fix this build step, deploy it
to Kubernetes, and we'll call Pang CRM finished.
We are done with ping.
David, is there any sensible way of running
build kit with Docker compose yet?
Yes. You just have to expose that environment
variable, which is actually what I've got. So
if I do a ENV
grab
build
kit.
If you just set this in your shell
environment, when you do a Docker compose build,
you actually do use build kit.
No?
It doesn't look like build kit.
I don't think you do. Oh, no. That
was the old step.
So I think in your CR, you might
not be using Docker Compose,
which is fine. And you'll get that password.
I we got it.
That's a nice way of running build kit.
Feel very disappointed.
You can manually do
oh, woah. Ah, there we go.
So oh, because Docker Compose doesn't depend on
Docker
CLI,
I don't think.
There you go.
Docker
Compose needs the daemon.
But I don't think it needs the Docker
CLI, and this
fails out and uses the Docker CLI.
Either that or docker post has a build
kit baked into it. But, I mean, build
kit is just a library that docker uses
when you do a docker image builds. Compose
is probably using the same library and it
it may not actually be using
The name of the docker daemon. I think
it's running the CI command.
Okay. So yeah. There you go. Compose. I
don't know that. That's cool. Compose Docker CLI.
I'm just gonna add that to my shell.
I always wanna use BuildKit now.
In fact, Leo already popped in. Hey.
Excuse me. Alright.
Let's separate this out.
What we're gonna do is
I know the naming here is terrible,
but I
mean, we we we've already worked out that
we need everything, right, to do the compose
or auto loader stuff. So
gonna do this in its own step.
Yeah.
Sorry. And oh, yep. Sorry. I made the
wrong one.
And then down here, we saw what that
worked there. We can do from
and
from
build FPM composer, and we're gonna copy everything
to the same location.
The only reason we're adding on this extra
step is just so that composer doesn't make
its way into this image when we ship
it to production. So just it removes an
attack vector, essentially.
Then our tests run.
In fact, our APM does this here.
We already have that step.
We've done here, but then we've got our
test here.
Getting so confused.
We don't need this step, so that can
go away.
And we ship our build FBM.
So we can build this and deploy that
to Kubernetes now. So let's just do that.
The slight annoyance is that it means that
it's gonna read the composer step's gonna rebuild
every time we touch a file.
Like,
it's nice to do it'd be nice to
do that two step thing if
you depend on
I guess as this is for prod,
we don't care as much. Is that right?
Maybe it's I I guess it would it's
still be nice to use the build cache.
I mean, there are you know, you can
do a cache from on a Docker CLI
to reuse a cache from a previous build.
So let's try and make that work. So
we can just say copy composer dot JSON.
It's closer dot JSON. We'll do the initial
composer install. Then we'll copy everything.
And then
we'll dump the auto loader. Let's see if
that works. So
and the thing that could go wrong here
is that this copies over our vendor directory.
But we might be okay because it should
do a merge in a Dockerfile copy rather
than a replace.
So
docker image build, we call this PHP prod
target or build FPM
angle.
Kinda where we are right now.
What we should see now the first time
is the docker compose install will take a
little bit of time.
If we rerun that again,
it should work.
Yep. And the with a very good comment
there.
Because I didn't change
I didn't change ownerships of the fail, and
I do have this all running as root.
So we'll we'll bring that in once we
confirm it works.
I should have maybe pulled in composer too.
Get the speed improvements.
There's a pull request on there at the
moment that offers another massive speed improvement.
Oh, really?
On addition to what they already optimized for
composer two? Yeah. It's not merged yet, but
it's
somehow in the solver eliminates
loads of the nonworking
root combinations to check. So they're seeing, like,
ten seconds going to four seconds. I
think Leo was trying to push my buttons
today.
Make sure you copy the composer dot lock
as well. Mhmm.
No.
I mean, I think I've ranted about this
in every episode so far in the series.
I we don't need a lock file. Docker
is our idempotency. Docker is our auditability. Everything
that we need to know is is there.
Lock
files, I would argue, should only be used
on a non container based deployment,
which means you also don't commit a lock
file into git.
I'm not gonna rant about it again, but
maybe we should maybe I'll organize
a bigger conversation
around lock files and container workloads in the
future.
I think what we said was if you
know that that exact version that's been tested
is going to production, you don't need to
connect the lock.
Well, the lock fail is giving you a
guarantee that if I do a composer install,
again, I get the same dependencies. When I
build on a container, I don't need that
semantic anymore.
So all you're really doing is restructuring your
you're making that very explicit operation to update
your dependencies. Whereas in a container based workflow
with good continuous integration and tests,
I always wanna opt in to those security
updates and updates to my packages in general.
So I would never, I personally never commit
a log file of container based development.
That's an argument for not putting the log
files the log files in your container.
And in git. That's not an argument for
omitting them in git.
Why?
Because putting them in git guarantees other things
that aren't to do with production. Things like
all the developers are working off the same
set of dependency.
But I want a developer to get those
updates just as quickly as my production image
so they can actually notice the errors locally
before it gets to production.
I mean, you should always be using the
latest and greatest versions within semantic reasoning, of
course. Like, you're not gonna go and upgrade
from three to four. But I always wanna
get patch updates
and minor updates in my in my code
as fast as possible. That way, it's not
this horrible ceremony. It's all we're gonna update
the packages. That's the first of the quarter
or whatever. And you have this whole thing
where we do it and then check for
run our tests and check for bugs and,
like, really, you just wanna do this often
as frequently as possible and get that feedback
loop as tight as you can. So does
that mean in your compose JSON and your
packages JSON, you've got just star as the
constraint?
No. I still use semantic version. I still
say get me two dot x. I just
I'm never gonna do a backwards compatibility major
update. I will do minors and patches automatically
though.
So our composer auto rules are failed because
there's nothing in the database seats.
Oh, okay. Now I remember. The the problem
was this is doing an auto loader by
default, wasn't it?
It was actually configured.
You're looking at one place.
Close it, Jason. Yeah.
And we changed it to false.
It was true.
That was failing for when we wanted we
were trying to build just the vendor folder
first.
Then then
oh, it's just annoying, isn't it? This is
when we were sort of using the container
for dev as well, was it?
Hold on. I can't remember what command. So
this is just running the install without the
dump bottle loader.
Mhmm.
And install needs
other things.
I I'm not gonna fight that because we're
almost at the end of our session. So
we will go back to copy the world.
And we should we can always do no
scripts. Right? Let's do no scripts. Let's make
this work properly.
It's because, like, some post install hooks, but
then expect us to be there.
I can't remember the flag. Is it just
that?
Yeah. Yeah.
K. But we want all we wanna do
is take the capabilities on, download our dependencies,
and don't do anything else. Everything else will
happen in the dump hot loader. Or do
I need to do another install to get
those scripts to run?
Oh, it's like for
Well, let's rebuild that again. The no scripts
should stop the
the database seed stuff from triggering. We will
want that to happen slightly. We want that
to happen when we bring in the rest
of the code so we can leverage to
build cache. So again, unfortunately, this will take
a few minutes.
But I should be able to run this
again when it is complete, and we should
see the cache used for the dependencies.
The nice thing about that is when I
ship a production image to a container registry
somewhere, I can use the previous build as
a cache from
that if the composite dot json hasn't changed,
that wouldn't rerun that step. Even if the
local build agent is not aware of that
cache, which is really nice. I like it.
Cool.
Now we just need to kill another minute
and a half while that runs.
What would speed up your
Sorry, Kevin?
What do you add the step that makes
it Composer two?
Is there a an image for Composer two?
It composes self update. Oh, there might be
an image by now. They want some sort
of alpha.
There's a self update command you can do
that pushes it. Oh, there is. Okay. Yeah.
We'll we'll use Composer two then
once I've shown that the cache works.
So cache form lets you cache
from a another remote
image?
How does it work?
Yes. So I will answer that. I will
also point out Leo's question.
You are right. We discovered that in the
last session that the no loader
is on by default, but we actually did
disable it in the composer dot JSON.
Tada.
Because it did it did annoy me. I
did get frustrated.
That that's to say it was optimization. It
might still dump auto loads dot PHP.
So it might still do some work to
make the auto load, and then we'll we're
gonna have interview and optimize the
We're upload PHP files. Right?
Okay.
I guess we're gonna find out in a
moment.
And if that is gonna fail, we're definitely
gonna want composer too. So
spring that in.
Yeah. It's generating a load fail.
Damn you.
Okay. So what we're actually saying here is
we we want no auto load. We'll do
it explicitly on our own step. There's no
auto loader.
Never. Whatever.
Last time. I'm not running this command again.
This should be quick.
Is it not colon two?
Yes. It is. Thank you.
Oh, well, it's That's the last time I'm
running it. I'm not running it again again.
Okay. Right. Cool. No worries. That's the cool
comparison. But we did it quick on the
install.
Oh, and the output's different too. The composer
too. I know we got some parallelism going
on there.
That is do you actually built into plugins
for composer to make it work parallel? Is
that built into composer too now then, I
guess?
It's got faster so solver in parallel downloads.
It's it's much faster. I think.
Yeah. Yeah. You're right. Just this one, whichever
one has in their Docker files.
Okay. So what's important here
is we got past the composer install.
We're now in step six of seven, which
failed because of a flag.
The good news is I should be able
to run that, and it should resume from
step seven of seven.
That's cached. Perfect.
See? I love it when stuff works.
I mean, I have a production Docker image.
And now if you were to change a
PHP but not a composite dependency, does it
use the same cache?
Yes. It will. So if I change
where's the where's the PHP code app? Right.
Let's
change kernel dot PHP.
I'll just say hello.
When we run this, our composer dot JSON
and composer installer should be cached.
Oh.
It's because you oh, why
is that copied? Oh, no. It it worked.
Yeah.
Yeah. That that was right.
But we want to do the composer install
stuff because nothing changed on composer's requirements. Yeah.
But it was cached. See? Composer composer install.
This is the second composer install that ran.
But do we want to
Well, we got a second one.
That's for the To trigger the To trigger
the scripts.
It was It did do its job. It
did use the cache.
But it did something. It did seven seconds
of stuff.
Oh, yeah. It still run the scripts.
It didn't it didn't fetch the dependencies.
Do do that again. There's a progress bar.
Hello too. Right? Well, the output format.
Oh, it's downloading stuff.
Alright. So how can I tell a composer
to run
oh, that's the dev dependencies? Why is it
download in PHP unit?
Because you have a dash node dev. You
want double dash node dev on there.
I thought I did.
On both?
Oh, yeah.
Can I just run composer scripts?
Is there a way that I can just
check out the scripts without the install?
You can close the help without
dash dash.
Excuse me. You've got that one so many
times.
Oh, because it
That is Yeah. Okay. This.
Why does it not list subcommands?
To compose a list.
It says in there somewhere. Compose a list.
Okay.
Run script. Run what? Run run. Okay. Composer
run is what we want. So let's remove
that.
I don't know why it's fetching those
dependencies.
I know.
It's because we're doing copies
it's because we're doing copies copy everything, and
we're maybe can copying the compose a lot
from the host.
Well, you have to specify a script. It
doesn't run all scripts.
That that's fine. Let's leave that as That's
what you care about.
So, David, in Docker ignore, is Composer locked
there?
If it's not, then what's happening is composer
lock's been copied from your host machine.
In those steps, and that's why it's in
a different state when we do the second
install.
Gotcha.
So if we run this once,
we should get complete cache. Yep. And then
if I modify PHP again
There we go. Okay. Cool. So we got
a cache even even
though we modified PHP, we did not have
to actually
technically do a composer install again
Except for the one where we're running the
scripts. JSON file, I assume this will then
start downloading stuff.
If we modify composer dot JSON, it will
invalidate the cache, and it will refresh all
of the dependencies.
Even if it's just How do you compose
a cache for dependencies that were already downloaded?
It uses the image cache if it is
available.
So yes. Now, of course, I've I I'm
it depends on my CI system, but there
may be a I may wish to run
this without a cache. It's really common for
production builds at least.
The
okay. And actually four, so I complete rebuild
of everything. But composer itself comes with its
own cache as well. So if you've got
10 packages, nine of them are the exact
same version down to the patch version and
one was changed. It would only load it
would load them in from cache and then
download the new one. Not in the Docker
image build, that cache won't exist.
Right.
And it'll be there.
But if you're caching from a previous image,
that might happen. If you cache from a
previous image, then yes. It will have access
to some compulsory cache.
And if you had a
a named volume with it, then potentially use
volumes with the Docker image build. So that's
it's not it's not an option.
Yeah. Running this run time after the images.
So Right. Okay.
Okay.
And to make build secrets because someone mentioned
it in the chat.
Was there a question on secrets?
Someone just mentioned the dash dash SSH
option in build.
Okay. Do we have time to convince the
secrets today?
The short version is if you want to
we can open it up from a private
repo, you have to do some extra stuff
using, I think, a build secret. So it's
got your SSH keys.
Relatively new. What? About twelve months old? Doesn't
work with Docker Compose yet.
Sorry. Let's not talk about it.
Here we go.
Yeah. So if if you do need access
to stuff like that, there is a way
to do it. I guess, when we tackle
the
the non ping CRM Laravel application and we
are doing a bet more with the images,
then we can we can handle that. I
guess, the main use case is,
you know, if you've got private composer.
Like, for your composer install, it won't work
without that secret and you don't want to
do you don't want that. You don't want
your token or your secret inside the image
which is available for people to kind of
hack or inspect and steal it. So you
would choose a build secret which is then
a a way to inject the femoral things
into the build process.
But
no requirement for that right now.
We won't tackle it.
And just with it being half two, we're
not even gonna be able to do the
Kubernetes deployment but now, but we're in a
pretty good shape. And I think we did
do a Kubernetes deployment on the first episode,
didn't we? Yeah. Okay. Cool. So that that's
still available to people if they wanna check
it out. I will push this code. We
will call ping CRM complete. We got everything
working that we wanted to work.
I will talk to Alex and Kiran afterwards.
We will find a more real world application
that has all these extra components so we
can tackle scheduling queues,
integration tests. I think it's really important. And
we will have an episode dedicated to actual
Kubernetes production stuff.
Yep.
Awesome.
Great. Thank you. Sorry?
Great.
Alright. Awesome. Cool. Well, thank you both for
joining me. This was another pleasure again. I
hope it was useful for the people at
home. We will continue this.
I don't know when, but we will tweet
out very soon.
Thanks again. Have a nice day everyone.
Bye.